hey everybody Doug Walker here I'm sick
I'm getting a lot better uh yeah I've
gotten a lot better we're going to film
the review probably while you're
watching this I'm filming the next
review but sadly that means no editorial
today what we're gonna do about it is
the editorial is written I just I
couldn't film it so I'm gonna film it
next week and so it's still gonna be
tight in the sequel month it's just
gonna be you know a delay so the the
review is still coming out next week and
the editorial for sequel month will come
out the week after and after that we'll
just go back to sort of the normal and
establish of critics
it was the norovirus which I've never
had before and I've had stomach flus
before but this this was the worst this
was awful and literally the morning I
woke up my wife did some research on and
just like apparently everyone got it the
exact same morning idea cuz it was on
the news it was spreading like wildfire
it's super contagious I had to do
something I never done before I had to
cancel a con a Comi con I had to cancel
savlya which I felt so bad cuz I was
building it up and everything and a lot
of our people here got sick my brother
got sick and Tamara got sick so I'm so
so sorry it really sucks but a us
feeling awful would be I don't want
contaminate other people at the
convention because apparently this is
like uber contagious so yeah you you
know the set up now and I'm so sorry I
couldn't get you an editorial this week
but it will be up two weeks from now and
the regular review of Garfield - that's
still gonna be up a week from today so
guys I'm already feeling better so I
know nifa well wishes or anything just
give me a heads up on what's going on so
that's about it and hope all is well no
talk to you later